Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
what's interesting too is that there's all these different approaches to
strength and conditioning,
and that's one of the reasons why I wanted to talk to you because one of the
things that I'd seen was,
um,
Matt working out with you and your guys and he was doing all kinds of crazy
stuff.
Um,
like when you devise a plan,
like for an athlete,
like a Matte Brown or someone like that,
like,
what do you do?
You work with them first to try to figure out what they're capable of and then
think about like,
what their style is.
Like.
Obviously you're going to have a different,
uh,
a different need if you're a striker versus grappler.
Well,
one thing we did,
we tried to get him more to air condition to do five minute rounds and
recovering in one minute.
When I worked,
everything was five minutes and minute recovery.
Some guys had went through eight rounds.
A lot of guys there was able to do that.
I mean,
pretty good fighters,
you know,
13,
13 wins and,
and,
uh,
you know,
pro fights,
stuff like that.
So just word of recovery.
Uh,
I want to maximize the amount of work I can do it five minutes and then be able
to cover in one minute and do it again repeatedly.
That's all I ever did work in five minute intervals.
So did you work with guys that you use heart rate monitors and like how did you
decide that?
Have they ever done any of that?
Really never know.
My friend John Sailor is got Shinnecock Jujitsu.
These basically I started almost really the first MMA school in America.
If you think about,
cause he was judo,
Jujitsu Samba,
but also striking and he started in 1985.
Oh Wow.
And he does everything by heart rate where we do things by percentages.
Uh,
okay.
I said we trade by an,
uh,
rates of velocity,
speed,
strength training at 75 to 85%.
He would do heart rate's like that.
And like if you and I would grapple,
if we could talk to each other for a half hour,
that'd be optimal.
You know me and you can talk while we're doing it.
And that's optimal heart rate that,
that way.
So he kept track of heart rates,
kind of basically how we do percentage of one rep Max.
So meaning that it's optimal if you could still talk while you're doing right,
sure.
Circuitry and optimally you're new.
You're not like,
you know,
that's how I would be in,
so,
but if you're gonna fight,
like if you're in a fight and it's a very high paced fight,
it's very likely that you're going to achieve much higher rates of heart rate
would be much more exhausted.
That's right.
But see,
that would be up to much how we train our speed date.
Like today for squatting and deadlifting is up the mud.
They do a 25 squats at one way and two,
and for speed,
strength acceleration and two and 20 dead lifts.
And then the other days Max effort.
And that's what you're talking about.
What you go all out and around someone's pushing you,
you know,
they're trying to take you out,
so you've got to fight back.
So,
uh,
it would see it always changes.
You can't do the same thing.
It's called law of accommodation few night.
Uh,
if you and I grappled at the same rate all the time,
I would actually catch up to you.
You know,
so you'd have to be able to maximize your potential and run me in the dirt.
So that's why you got to have two different days.
You know,
you can't just do the same type of work all the time.
I think that's where a lot of projects go wrong.
They get word,
he paced yourself too much.
You see that before fighters,
you know,
the old fighters cover up and uh,
I,
I watch fights all my life from Rudolph Roberto Duran and Muhammad,
our lab watched him and I'm sure you're,
you've got to be a big fight fan and you'd just see how some people get in a
scheduled amount of work per it and that's when you can beat him.
Take him out like another word.
You know,
I'm going to make you go at my pace,
not you go with my opinion,
I'm going to follow your page.
You'll make you feel mine.
So varying the intensity of the training,
varying how you do your training.
You think that's very important?
Very important.
Hence the change all zone.
So does it have to change all the time because the body just adapts and gets
efficient.
Right?
As well as ask why the law of accommodation is you adapt to a training loader
stimulus.
And if you don't change it,
you get no better.
You actually go backwards.
So you can actually got to change these two meters.
Tom Does a lot of stuff of war barrels.
We push where bells around for half a mile running,
sometimes heavier weight walking.
Um,
get in a belt squat all it's very grueling.
And then just a maximal strength.
Went to simple things like deadlifts,
good mornings.
We do a lot of stuff holding the bars in their elbows.
Tom Has,
you do a lot of that.
It's almost like,
you know,
grappling.
Yep.
Humbling.
And then other times,
you know,
you got to do quick stuff,
so quicker paced stuff.
So you know,
it does.
How fights are they number one pace now,
how do you like create a schedule?
Like,
say,
if you're working with a guy and you,
you,
you know,
we don't believe in schedule,
you don't believe in it.
Now,
even my gosh,
I had the strongest gym in the world,
spoke about 140 all time world record at breakfast and Tom can verify at
breakfast in the morning at six o'clock,
six 30.
We decide what we're going to do that day cause she strengths measured in time.
It's not measured in weight.
It's majored in time marrow,
talking about velocities.
And uh,
so we just pick an exercise like for you,
if we did a real low box squat,
didn't take longer than squatting 800 pounds,
you're going to squat a inner band.
You,
you choked me out after a while.
I'm going to tap.
All right.
Well if we run after a while,
I'm going to run out of watch it and I'm going to quit.
Say thank for strength.
You can know strange,
so long.
So loans you strained at least at length of time or longer,
you're going to break a classical lift and squat,
bench and deadlift.
Yeah.